Wonder Woman 3 has been canceled and it
looks like the end of the snyderverse
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
James Gunn and Peter saffron in a
meeting recently with Patty Jenkins
announced that Wonder Woman 3 was not
going to happen in its current form now
apparently Patrick Jenkins had gone as
far as the script and setting up a lot
of the early pre-development work it was
when she was presenting this the James
Gunn and Peter saffron along with Pam
Abdi and Michael DeLuca uh made the
decision and announced it to Patty that
Wonder Woman 3 would not be going ahead
now this has come with a lot of rumors
going around about how the DC were going
to redirect their current plans with the
DC now that James Gunn and Peter saffron
are in charge now initially it looked
like Black Adam was actually going to do
very well at the box office but he
didn't and then Henry Cavill appearing
in Black Adam and reignited a lot of
excitement that we're going to get to
see the Man of Steel to or some other
iteration of Superman with him in the
part now there's been a couple of
interviews since that have cast a little
bit about on that assumption and I've
heard some rumors coming from Warner
Brothers as well now it does seem that
initially there was a lot of excitement
around picking and cherry-picking from
the Snyder verse they were going to
bring back Henry cavilla Superman
because they liked that character Gal
Gadot was going to get a Wonder Woman
movie even though it was going to maybe
need a rewrite that looks like that from
now been canceled there was even a rumor
that Ben Affleck could return as Batman
but in a much darker version of that
character a version of Batman the Ben
Affleck desperately wanted to do in the
first place
now there was this idea that they could
continue with the Snyder verse or the DC
Universe that that's been established
but they would cherry pick the best bits
and forget the bad bits now I'm being
told that there are very serious
conversations going on right now within
the DC that James Gunn and Peter saffron
are seriously considering scrapping
everything that happened previously so
everything that happened within the
Snyder universe will be erased they will
simply put a bow on it and forget it
happened
so this would kind of make sense in lots
of ways the Batman
um with Robert Patterson did did pretty
well and we're looking at a TV series to
follow that up with a penguin and almost
certainly going to be getting a sequel
of that there could also be other
spin-offs from that there are increasing
groomers that actually Batman Beyond is
going to get produced and that that will
be a live action very gritty very
hardcore movie
there are lots of conversations that
actually they want to take the DC down a
very dark very grown-up adult path that
they look at things like Deadpool and
decide that actually these movies don't
have to be 12 A's anymore we can make a
movie that's an 18 or a 15 and then we
can actually make the movie we all want
to see
particularly with the character of
Batman that to me only makes sense you
shouldn't make a Batman movie that's a
12a that character is a very violent the
whole point of it that it's dark and
gritty if you make that movie into a pig
in children's movie like they did with a
couple of the previous Batmans George
Clooney I'm looking at you then it
really takes away from the point of the
character he's supposed to be a
vigilante he's supposed to be violent
the Christian Bale version of the Batman
is the prime example of that so what
does this mean for the DC moving
forwards now there is obviously a very
large Financial issue going on at Warner
Brothers they are in significant debt
and they are trying to consolidate lots
of their IP and really trying to
reorganize a lot of their business so
that they can stop hemorrhaging money
their CEO of Warner Brothers Discovery
David zazlab has so far been doing a
pretty bloody good job he has made a
significant effort to towards cutting
off as much of the fat as possible and
he's moving forwards with the projects
that he thinks will make money now this
is coming off the back of some
significant failures for the DC the
original Justice League movie Lost lots
of money the Zack Snyder cut didn't
really make any of it back 1984 Wonder
Woman was a massive failure Black Adam
didn't do as well as hoped and obviously
Batgirl got cut before we even got to
see him but who knows some of these
changes could be a good thing Peter
zaffron and James Gunn really do seem to
have
um a good take on where they want to
take the DC and that isn't going to
involve a lot of what's come previously
it does mean we're not going to see
Jason Momoa or as Aquaman again which is
a shame
um and honestly if Aquaman 2 doesn't do
very well at the box office I think that
will really be the final nail in the
coffin of what we call the Snyder verse
there are rumors actually that Jason
Momoa is already lining up to come back
as a completely different character
within the DC but those currently are
only rumors but it really would show
that that Snyder verse was over and the
Aquaman was over I've always said
Aquaman if you actually look at it as a
movie isn't very good it's just that
Jason Momoa as Aquaman is fantastic and
it made up for the shortcomings of the
movie it's a shame we never got to see
Ben Affleck personally an actor I really
like
um in a Batman role that he wanted to do
that he was pushing for a really dark
gritty version of the Batman but I liked
Robert Pattinson's take on it even
though that movie was way too damn long
it was actually a really good film I
want to see a director's cut that's
shorter for once but other than that I
really enjoyed it and I'm looking
forward to what they're going to do with
the Penguin and then looking forward to
what they're going to do with the Batman
2
and if Batman Beyond gets made the way
that I hope it does wow that'll be
amazing
so Warner Brothers are going to continue
with the animated DC movies and to us
they've been doing a brilliant job with
those but it does look like there's
going to be a complete reset on the DC
Universe moving forwards and that we are
not going to be getting Henry Cavill as
Batman Gal Gadot as Wonder Woman or all
of these other characters now I suspect
these decisions are still up in the air
slightly but really if the Flash doesn't
do very well or Aquaman 2 doesn't do
very well that really will be the last
time we see these characters for a
little while
but guys tell me what you think what do
you think about these decisions do you
actually think putting a lid on the side
of this is a good idea do you think we
should just move on from that and try to
forget it ever happened or would you
like to see some of these characters
return get in the comments and tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
the Bell notification really helps us
out and as always if you enjoy the
content and you want to become a fully
fledged side tracker please consider
hitting the join button
please stay safe I'll see you next time
[Music]